fighting around chance has been raging
for weeks over the last 24 hours
kremlin-backed separatists insisted
they'd encircled the city a claim
initially rejected by the ukrainians
but pictures showed chechens and
russian-backed separatist fighters
celebrating in the streets
the six kazakh regiment named after
ottoman platop together with our
fighting friend our fighters liberated
the city of lizzie chang's ahmed is
power cossacks are power together we are
power
in a statement on social media the
ukrainian military said it had taken the
decision to withdraw in order to
preserve the lives of what it described
as ukrainian defenders adding we will be
back we will definitely win the
ukrainians claimed until the last
possible moment the city was still under
its control and was inflicting losses on
advancing troops in other parts of the
region
there are such risks that lugansk region
will be completely occupied there is
such risk and they are understood by us
[Music]
we cannot say that today that lucidchart
is under control there is fighting on
the outskirts of lusichansk our task is
to have fire superiority
russia now claims it has full control of
luhansk region one of its key warriors
after it abandoned plans to overrun the
capital and it's done so after weeks of
slow progress
now it will turn its full attention to
neighboring donetsk the other province
which makes up the donbass
moscow back separatists have been
fighting ukraine in the donbass since
2014 on the eve of the war russia
recognized two breakaway republics now
it has control of one the second becomes
the new front line in the war in ukraine
alan fisher al-jazeera keefe